how many sprays do you use
like 12. what up gq this your boy little
dirt and these are my essentials let's
get
keep me focused keep me sane perfect for
the air not too much not too late
i'm just big on my music so i i like to
listen to my music 24 7 to make sure
everything is right
like in the headphones you can hear
everything i actually got like 10 pedals
like losing them people be stealing them
so i got like 10 pips
[Music]
it's my new chain to my dear cousin
newski
and i ain't got it man that's a picture
on the back
i came in a lot it's like my piece of my
mirror
remember i don't know it was custom made
easy little jeweler you do most of my
chair when i first got i ain't allowed
to win every day
and that's like a special cage because i
don't want to get
damaged i don't want to i mean i want to
bring it out one time
it's mostly dependent than the and make
it happen put the weight on them it
means so much
it mean much more much to me than the
clarity but the clarity just adds to it
of course
playing my cheetos i'm addicted to them
i can't stop eating them i grew up off
of them i eat them
every day living i'm a spice type guy
so like i like a lot of spice anytime i
snack but
i try my best not to do them before
interviews because i have my mouth red
and your fingers they stain your hands
too i'm a professional man i
either straight out of the bag or every
time i dig in the bag and eat them
i'll wear my finger on i got a whole
setup over there with chips
calvin klein it's not fit 100 cotton
i can't live without them these look
most likely like everyday t-shirts
so i keep a whole pack of me everywhere
i go buy one a white tee
you get that [ __ ] you can stain anything
the cut of it
i'm saying it's fit it ain't too long it
ain't too tight need too loose
it's like perfect fit so if i uh well
one i can afford to back me up fake and
dirty
watch my duo clone for me
keep with me 24 7. smell good
never know what you gonna run into
growing up i just used to just wash up
and
that was it and i started knowing the
point the importance of hygiene so i
like clone
flossing getting my teeth clean i'm
saying i just like to smell good
like 24 7 no matter what it's like a
rich smell like you come from the
trenches
like 12.
next item is floss can't live without it
definitely because you you
floss anyway but since i got a grill and
like
i got a floss 24 7. i eat and you will
have like
a certain type of smells in your mouth
it's your breath
it become addictive you put the floss
anyway but every time i eat some of my
floss cause it's just like getting
food on my teeth so when i take these
out i'ma still be flossing like
24 seconds inside my cosmetic bag i
can't leave without it because i don't
even feel right like without flaws i
don't feel right
it feels like uncomfortable it's so
crazy before i got these i had
eight cavities now i got nothing now
my lamborghini truck favorite cop to
yours
can't live without it sporty look
fast cars did you let anybody else drive
it
um how can i say it i let mature people
drive
we're gonna treat it like it is look
crazy speed on the crazy
look up can't go wrong with them again
anyway
it's a vibe though next item
hard drive i keep all my music going
i keep folding with the same type of
music going to case i lose one
and i like this brand because it got a
password so if i lose it
and if you find it you don't you don't
want to return it you got to pass it
i used to actually just go off email
then when
emails get hacked people leak the music
or i forget a password
i can't get the song back so
i got to start using the hard drive so
every time i leave the studio i just put
my music on the hard drive
and make sure you know music anybody
losing a child gotta hold the hand of
this 24 7.
because this was your money at call of
duty i just started playing call of duty
during the quarantine and got addicted
to it i've been playing like 20.
i'm getting better because i've never i
was never playing at all but now
i learned how to uh to live stream and
twitch you know
all the good stuff like gaming gonna be
super it's already big but it's gonna be
bigger sports in a minute
2k like basketball we grew up out there
that was like the go-to game when i
started um
my gaming product name crown so heavy
and big they taught me how to play call
of duty it was like they start coming
ideas like
get paid for them you can do this you
can laugh at him and i started getting
into it more
but i ain't i had enough to do but um
sitting out just play the game with the
chord
studios were totaled down so it was
different i'm showing the playstation gq
but you know i'm playing this too
my phone can't live without it stay
updated
stay connected to the world talk to my
family my kids on the phone
it's really important like i feel lost
without my phone i had lost my phone in
new york before
when i was in chicago i'm so mad but i
was doing the interview
so that was lucky they had um kept it
for me and shipped it back to before i
started using the hard drive
so i had like all my music on my phone
all the pitches that i know i couldn't
get back
i dropped it so much that i had to get a
kick at the point
it's a louis vuitton case it really just
protects the back of it from breaking
you know it don't protect the front it's
really more so faster than anything
i appreciate y'all checking out my 10
essentials i hope y'all like